I was reading through your files today I
get files on everybody and dossier a
dossier if you will a CIA dossier and I
was flipping through it and one of the
things that listed under your many
talents is that you
besides being a fantastic actor you like
to paint toenails and I didn't know if
that's a joke or if that's a real thing
so here's how that happened
first of all it's a giant pain in the
ass all right so great your canvas is
very small okay
but my girlfriend was looking at all
these incredible Otoniel thing art
online and I said I can do that she said
oh yeah put your money where your mouth
is and I so I had to I did actually
that's not what she said she actually
didn't say but she said my girlfriend
Spanish she did she speaks English
without an accent I never know she was
foreign but all the English idioms she
doesn't really
it's them a little bit wrong says really
put your money in your mouth I don't
think either one I've ever dated oh
there was another one okay look I'm
gonna be honest with you I'm gonna put
all my cards on the table because I
think no don't put any cards on the
tables she says cars cars or one time we
were at dinner there's a good one it was
yeah it was at well if I had a nickel
for every time I heard that well
apparently you've heard it twice yeah I
don't want to give you a break this is
actually my she's very smart lady she's
actually a card-carrying member of Mensa
getting her master's in in very
intelligent very smart just the English
is not pretty tricky yeah English is
tricky and and and you said that she
insists that you try out your your I
might say handiwork but your footwork I
did it and you did I think we have a
sample of your work here that is really
good
that's really good I wanted to keep it
interesting for me so the hero stuff I
liked so we did one foot Marvel in one
foot DC that's fantastic
Thanks that's incredible well that keeps
the relationship fresh it's not easy
work I'm gonna tell you are you I'm
curious I know that you talked about
being a celebrity and and and being
someone who's increasingly well-known
you use an alias when you go to
Starbucks now some people do that for
fun yes but you don't use the name
Nathan Fillion when you go to Starbucks
and get a coffee I'd like to try to I
like to keep a low profile and one of
the things I found out was you know if
you someone announces your name and
someone thinks maybe you might be
somebody then they hear your name then
they know right so I put a false name
when I order my Starbucks so I use I use
George Clooney you think that's true
this is true you use George clean I
think we have Twitter we're gonna pick
shrug it you have George Clooney on
yours yeah yeah so they don't look over
they go okay but can they look over they
go that's not George Clooney perfect
disguise it takes all the pressure off
now do you get bugged a lot you get do
you do you get recognized a lot when you
go around and that you know because it's
a town where there are you know tour
buses driving around checking people out
when I moved to when I first moved to LA
I see those star line tours I thought
one day I'm gonna wave I'm gonna be
somebody and I'm gonna wave with those
buses and they're gonna go that was that
guy yeah and this just happened
this happened last summer I was we were
doing two other actors of myself we
auctioned off a lunch for charity food
on foot is a wonderful organization here
in town getting almost people homes and
we auctioned off the lunch this
wonderful couple came from Australia we
rented an SUV and we went from tap we
were like rest up appetizers here main
course over here dessert over here we're
all over to town and we pulled up next
to one of those start line
vans it's a van it's an open van
everybody's out there they can't be over
tops they don't die in the heat and this
lady said Oh what the iron em here in a
car full of celebrities I said well
let's say hello and I'd put the window
down and I say everybody in the band
this is jr. born he was on revenge and
in Teen Wolf and this is Michael trucco
he was on revenge and battlestar
galactica they're going oh my god
click click click click click they're
having a great time in Michael trucco
says and this is my friend Nathan he's
on Castle and they go close but no not
him not him but close